♪ ♪
>> Jesse: SO LET THE S FUNDING
BEGIN.
>> THOSE LIGHTS THAT ARE JUST
SHOOTING OUT FROM THE
LINCOLN MEMORIAL, ALONG THE
REFLECTING, IT’S ALMOST LIKE
EXTENSIONS OF JOE BIDEN’S ARMS
EMBRACING AMERICA.
IT WAS A MOMENT WHERE THE NEW
PRESIDENT CAME TO TOWN AND SORT
OF CONVENED THE COUNTRY IN THIS
MOMENT OF REMEMBRANCE COME OUT
STRETCHING HIS ARMS.
>> Greg: WOW, HE REALLY LET
HIMSELF GO.
>> THE 46TH PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES PUTTING HIS SOUL
INTO HIS FIRST ADDRESS.
>> HE GET THE KIND OF INAUGURAL
ADDRESS OF OUR PRESIDENCY WAS TO
GIVE, AS HOPEFUL AS THE MAN
DELIVERING IT.
>> WE SAW THE STEELY
DETERMINATION AND COMPASSION OF
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN.
>> WHAT A GREAT LOVE STORY
BETWEEN JILL BIDEN AND JOE BIDEN
AND WE HAVEN’T HAD A LOVE STORY
IN THE WHITE HOUSE FOR FOUR
YEARS.
>> Greg: IT IS A LOVE STORY
BETWEEN PRESS AND BIDEN.
THE NEW EDITOR EVEN ADMITS SHE
GOT CHILLS FROM JOE WHICH WE
HOPE ISN’T COBETA.
COCOVID-19.
THEY FRANTICALLY SPIT ON THE
OUTGOING GUY, TRYING TO OUTDO
EACH OTHER ON WHO IS MORE
RELIEVED THAT HER NATIONAL
NIGHTMARE IS OVER.
>> HOW A WELCOME SIGHT FOR MANY
AMERICANS, PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
LEAVING WASHINGTON.
>> IT WILL BE A LITTLE PATHETIC,
BUT TINY LITTLE CROWD AT JOINT
BASE ANDREWS.
>> IS ALMOST LEAVING TOWN I CAN
AUTOCRAT.
>> HE JUST LOOKS LIKE A SMALL
MAN.
>> HE JUST KNOWS HE IS LEAVING A
PARIAH AND NO ONE WANTS TO BE
SEEN WITH HIM.
>> FOR YEARS AND HE WENT THROUGH
AMERICAN CARNAGE.
A RIOT, A PANDEMIC.
CARNAGE.
>> Greg: IT’S AMAZING, THE
EMOTIONAL INTENSITY OF THEIR
CONFORMITY.
YOU COULD SET THEIR WATCH TO
THEIR LOCKSTEP.
THE PRESS ARE LIKE CHILDREN,
OVERJOYED THAT MOMMY’S DEADBEAT
BOYFRIEND FINALLY MOVED OUT OF
THE HOUSE EXCEPT THEY STILL
CAN’T QUIT AMERICA’S BAD BOY AT
ALL.
TRUMP HAS LEFT A TRUMP-SIZED
HOLE IN THEIR LIVES AND THEY ARE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO FILL
IT IN WITH WHAT.
THE MEDIA COVERAGE WILL BOUNCE
BETWEEN SOFTCORE FLAVORING
MASQUERADING AS HARD NEWS.
FOR EXAMPLE, DID YOU KNOW THAT
JOE HAS A PELLET ON, I GOT TO
SOURCES TO GO ON RECORD, TWO
PIECES WHO REMEMBER THE AWFUL
PAST UNDER THE FONZIE-GODZILLA
HYBRID THAT WAS TRUMP.
DON’T WORRY, THERE WILL NO NOT B
ANONYMOUS SOURCES AND THE MEDIA
IS GASSY, YOU WILL SEE THE
REGRET.
WHAT WILL THEY DO AFTER ALL
THESE AT BITTER EMOTIONAL
FAREWELLS WHEN THEY REALIZE
THEIR PRIMARY ENGINE OF PROFIT
CREATING HATE BASED ON THEIR OWN
LOATHING FOR TRUMP ARE FINALLY
GONE?
>> A LOT OF AMERICANS OF
GOODWILL SAW THE TRUE FACE OF
WHITE SUPREMACY SUPREMACY,
TRUMP-ISM AT ITS CORE.
WHAT’S PREVENTING US FROM COMING
TOGETHER TO FIGHT REAL ENEMIES
LIKE COVID-19 IS RACISM.
IT’S WHAT ALLOWED DONALD TRUMP
FREE REIGN TO TERRORIZING
WORKING PEOPLE FOR FOUR YEARS.
>> Greg: YOU ARE STILL HERE,
BUT NOT FOR LONG IF THEY CAN
HELP IT.
AND BY DAY, I MEAN MEDIA, KATIE.
WHO HAVE GONE BEYOND PARITY.
I GET IT, GREATEST INAUGURATION
EVER BUT, COME ON.
>> Katie: I HAVE ANOTHER ONE
FOR YOU.
ALL THE FASHION MAGAZINES, SO
TODAY, IT BRINGS AMERICAN
FASHION BACK INTO THE
WHITE HOUSE STARTING WITH A
SUBTLE SPARKLY COAT.
NOW I LOVE THE THOUGHT OUTFIT
THAT FIRST LADY JOE BIDEN WAS
WEARING TODAY BUT FIRST LADY
MELANIA TRUMP WAS A SUPERMODEL
AND A DESIGNER OF HIGH FASHION.
SO YOU KNOW.
THEY ARE GOING TO DO WHAT THEY
ARE GOING TO DO.
GET READY FOR IT, FOR YEARS.
THEIR FIRST OPPORTUNITY IS THE
PRESS SECRETARY WHO WILL BE OUT
AT 7:00 TO ASK FOLLOW-UP
QUESTIONS OF THE EXECUTIVE
ORDERS TODAY WHICH I’M SURE WILL
BE IN THE HONEYMOON PERIOD.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW I EXPRESS MY
OPINIONS HERE, THIS IS A
DISCUSSION SHOW.
WE DON’T CLAIM TO BE HARD NEWS
AS ESTEEMED AS THAT IS.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO PRETEND TO
BE OBJECTIVE NEWS ANCHORS WHO
ARE DROOLING, DROOLING AS THEY
WATCH THE EVENT.
IT SEEMS TO ME LIKE A BETRAYAL
OF AMERICA’S TRUST.
>> Juan: I DON’T SEE IT THAT
WAY.
IN FACT WHAT YOU HAVE IN AMERICA
IS MORE OPINION AND OPINION.
I WISH WE COULD GET BACK TO MORE
SIMPLE FACTS BUT SOME PEOPLE
MIGHT SAY THAT WAS BORING.
I DO THINK WHAT WE SEE IN THE
CONSERVATIVE ECHO CHAMBER IS
CONSTANT CAMPAIGN AND ATTACKS,
NICKNAMES AND BULLYING, I DON’T
LIKE IT.
BUT I THINK THAT SELLS FOR A LOT
OF PEOPLE.
SO THE CAMPAIGNING NEVER STOPS
AND WE DON’T GET TO SOLVING
PROBLEMS FOR THE COUNTRY, WE
NEVER GET TO TALK ABOUT
COMPROMISE AND PEOPLE WHO WANT
TO COMPROMISE ARE DISMISSED AS A
WEEK.
THEY ARE TERRIBLE.
THE EMPHASIS IS ALWAYS ON
SELLING GRIEVANCE, SELLING
GRUDGES, PICKING FIGHTS.
I GUESS THAT IS WHAT GETS A
PERSON TO COME BACK AND LISTEN
TO THE NEXT SHOW BUT FOR ME
THAT’S NOT WHAT GOVERNMENT
SHOULD BE ABOUT.
IT SHOULD BE IN THE NAME OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Greg: I THINK
BRETT KAVANAUGH WOULD AGREE WITH
YOU, AND JESSE, THIS IS WHY WHEN
WE LOOK AT THE STUFF YOU CANNOT
TRUST THIS INDUSTRY, THIS
INDUSTRY THAT WE ARE IN BECAUSE
HE’S WATCHING US TRANSFORM THE
BELIEF SYSTEM, OR THEIR
MENTALITY DEPENDING ON THE PARTY
PARTY.
>> Jesse: WELL, JUAN SAID
YESTERDAY THAT PEOPLE’S POLITICS
SHOULDN’T AFFECT THEIR JOB
PERFORMANCE SO WHEN YOU HEARD
ALL THOSE HARD NEWS REPORTERS
SAYING TRUMP’S A WHITE
SUPREMACIST, THAT WAS NOT
AFFECTED AT ALL BY THEIR
PERSONAL POLITICS.
HE HAS BEEN PROVEN TO BE A
CARD-CARRYING WHITE SUPREMACIST,
THAT’S HARD NEWS, RIGHT, JUAN?
OF COURSE NOT.
THAT’S A FAIR OPINION AFFECTING
THEIR JOB AND THAT’S WHAT THE
PROBLEM IS.
>> Greg: LAST WORD TO YOU
DANA.
WE DON’T PICK SIDES HERE BUT
THEY DO, DON’T THEY?
>> Dana: LET ME JUST SAY ONE
THING THAT THE BIDEN TEAM HAS
BENEFITED FROM.
THEY ARE EXTREMELY TIGHT-LIPPED.
THEY DO NOT LEAK, SO FAR.
THAT MIGHT CHANGE NOW THAT THEY
ARE AT THE WHITE HOUSE BUT THEIR
CAMPAIGN, NOW THE REPORTERS ARE
EXTREMELY FRUSTRATED, THEY HAVE
A DISCIPLINED APPROACH.
IF THEY CAN BRING THAT TO THE